[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
welcome back welcome back everyone to
the break room hey
[Applause]
yes this is our daily show that keeps
you updated on just what's going on in
nerd news from our very own break group
here at our secret headquarters on the
moon coming up today we're going to be
talking about big daddy michael waldron
giving us some sweet sweet updates
anakin's dead to who to whom oh
morbius just got weirder no possible
freaky got a little bit weirder guys
and everyone's asking where's waldo no
no no no we're asking where's neymore
remember who asked that yeah probably
underwater he's probably underwater and
and much like uh several times a week on
this show one of us is getting canceled
baby yes terminally cancelled that's
right uh i'm brandon barrick and i'm
here with a lot of my friends today we
got jessica clemens howdy howdy howdy
howdy howdy howdy howdy howdy howdy
howdy and we also got tommy bechtol oh
yeah i'm all fueled up electrolytes
coursing through my body no cramps here
guys i put a damper on the cramper yeah
yeah how's your gucci feeling today i'm
feeling gucci to moochie let me see
that's good here that's good
you know uh
hey we got super chats coming in already
today kodak2309 said it best easy that's
right yeah we keep it thank you and all
those super chats they go into our swear
jar now what's our swear jar we're not
allowed to curse on this show we've got
filthy mouths that just want to rip roar
away but we got to keep it clean for the
fcc because they won't let us be they
won't let me be me
but if if you do some super chats and
all those super chats accumulate up to a
hundred dollars one of us gets to swear
we get to buy a swear back from the from
big government like goonies we're all
down at the bottom of the well and you
guys are throwing super chats in and we
take one back yeah because it's our wish
it didn't come true that's right a 40
year old movie reference for all you
people people have watched goonies they
like new rock stars
she knows goonies and she's 13.
this 13 year old knows
ah speaking of 13 year olds uh we got to
do some headlines oh baby 13 year olds
uh i
there it is um i don't know why 13 year
olds uh would speak of headlines but but
this 39 year old certainly will uh
every show we're gonna start with some
headlines the big news of the day the
nerdy news that you all should be
keeping up with uh the writer of this
moment okay the loki and multi-verse of
madness writer michael waldron teased
some new story details for the upcoming
kevin feige star wars movie oh that he
is also writing wow this guy's taking
all the good writing gigs right now
he had this great quote it's not
necessarily a sequel or anything it
maybe has a little bit less of a it just
doesn't have a bunch of tv shows and
movies that you're servicing on top of
it the way i did with doctor strange so
it's nice it feels like a different
exercise
[Music]
bring me back my jedi well that is
exciting to hear right because i mean
star wars has as much fluff as like the
marvel universe it feels like if you
write anything in star wars it has to
have a storm trooper it's gotta have a
tie fight and it could still have all
those things but we have not seen a
fully divested of the skywalker saga
star wars property right we have yet to
see that but maybe this will be the
first one i i gotta be honest you gotta
service me a little bit you know i don't
mean that in a dirty way i need a
fluffer but i mean if it's just like a
different movie with things that have
nothing to do with the previous star
wars movies and tv then it's not really
star wars i agree with tommy i don't
mean to be a whiny little baby boy i'm
not gonna write a petition i'm not gonna
start a hashtag the only hashtag i
started is hashtag gucci to moochie
that's where you share some positive
news about your life what's going on
that's gucci to youtube okay
you share what's gucci to yucci okay and
we make it gucci to merchandise right
what's that three for me john
get that three for me jeffy speaking of
gucci uh i don't know why i keep doing
these terrible transitions obi-wan
director deborah chao did an interview
with entertainment weekly where she said
that not only is obi-wan set in a dark
time for to be a jedi you know because
most of them are dead or in hiding
during the time span of obi-wan but that
obi-wan in this series thinks anakin is
dead oh so sorry sorry
could be could be in for a rude
awakening yeah i was gonna say are we
gonna get a second darth vader like
harrowing moment where he's like i was
once your student and he's like anakin
me and oh god yeah this is me and
brandon
i was shook and i came to brandon i came
to zach earlier about this but we did
talk about the fact that so he does know
that anakin is vader but he doesn't know
because darth sidious told him he saw it
in the uh he heard the name darth vader
so as you know that day is going off
right
order
66 is happening
yoda shows obi-wan like a hologram of of
anakin kneeling before darcidius and in
the hologram he's like rise lord vader
yes and then yoda you know they talk a
little bit obi-wan and yoda and yoda's
like he's fully
become darth vader or he's fully lost to
darth vader yeah yeah so obi-wan has
heard the name dark okay so it won't be
totally he won't then he doesn't
and he's been in hiding so the rude
awakening is just going to be
he's going to know vader exists right
but once he
recognizes that's anakin that's where
the real okay you might just think like
oh i guess they kept the name darth
vader they don't got a lot of names
that makes me so mad that there's so
much confusion and continuity with just
like we don't remember everybody's name
that was also a busy day for him he
might have gotten through
today i barely remember what we did on
the break room yesterday so i'll cut our
dude obi-wan some slack
this is brandon hinted at this in the
intro okay this is an unconfirmed rumor
yes but it is a rumor producer john
first heard we were unable to confirm or
deny it supposedly if you go see the
film morbius in theaters now it's been
out i believe since the beginning of
april yeah uh the mid-credit scene has
been changed okay they removed they've
removed any mention of spider-man this
is the mid-credit scene not to spoil it
but to spoil it is when morbius drives
into sports card in the middle of the
desert vulture flies in they chat
they're like hey we should team up we
could do some good apparently they've
removed any mention of spider-man
vulture says that something like i think
our pal spider-man has something yeah so
now it just cuts to immediately like we
should team up now we don't know we
haven't seen it if you're out there and
you really want to go see power bs again
in theaters yes
maybe maybe you work at an amc or a
regal or whatever
peak your head into that that lonely
lonely morbius screening yeah uh we know
it can't be too crowded in there uh or
just swing by maybe as you're leaving
the multiverse of madness screening pop
your head in for that mid-credit scene
and keep us up-to-date save us from
having to find out ourselves i want to
say i see a chat up there from zell k
says the break room is better than porn
i just realized and my response to
zelkay is find a way to private message
me and i will fix that for you who are
not watching the right kind of porn
maybe maybe so i just realized what were
they watching right before the show i
just realized
well not to spoil something we talk
about later uh after re-watching
multiverse madness uh last night
you know after the opening scene with uh
defender strange in america turns out it
was a dream we see our 616 strange wakes
up in bed yeah right there's an open
laptop next to him in bed oh
now
you're watching netflix like the rest of
us in college oh yeah like
like i did it in college everybody knows
you watch porn on your phone okay that's
a good point yeah laptops are too much
work to watch
anyways boy we've gotten off track
but john is upset with us jeremy slater
who who the writer for the moon knight
series mentioned in an interview that
they cut a line of dialogue where steven
mentioned rama tut ramatat being another
name for king the conqueror right and
there was that great easter egg on the
back of the thugs jacket there was this
uh depiction of rama tut
apparently in the cut the cut line of
dialogue like steven was babbling off
the top of his head he was kind of
naming different gods he mentioned the
name rama tut it's interesting now
sometimes they cut stuff just for time
or because it doesn't quite work but
maybe that was intentional
they didn't want to tease people too
much with a king appearance there's too
much news we're hearing now about like
the things that we're cutting
i wonder if they just make like a
whiteboard of like
here's all the things we can leak out
that we were considering doing or just
say that we're considering doing that'll
make the fans go like oh oh that's crazy
like you know at one point we did think
about having peter venkman come in and
we thought that might be too crazy for
the viewers this happens a lot though
i was about to say it probably is such
an eye opener to everybody and such a
shock of like yeah when you're coming
out after and before so many other
properties in the mcu you have so much
stuff that you're like we have to just
throw this at a wall and then the
producers will come in and tell us not
to do it yeah
we have four versions of our screen and
we actually have we're gonna talk about
a similar situation in a little bit uh
but first we've got a new image from
thor love and thunder
look at that let me see let me see whoa
it looks like there's some chaos in the
background that could be a new asgard is
everything's on fire maybe that is
probably new asgard yeah well we see at
the end of that teaser when there's the
fight going on right
everything's going crazy in the town who
do you think is attacking new asgard in
that shot um
gore's not going to set fire to a bunch
of innocent people
it's the care bears
i gotta burn down new asgard sorry guys
i just also want to shout out right now
we got a super chatter that said zach
looking like zaddy
[Applause]
yeah he's upset oh he's upset i don't
know this is your disapproving daddy
i think you should do your homework and
go back to bed there's a new daddy in
town wow
now i know why this is better than porn
this makes sense now yeah well if you're
into a very specific kind of look uh
sure speaking of thor love and thunder
taika waititi the director of that in
the previous thor film is being super
secretive about russell crowe's row
russell crowe's role we know he's
playing
zeus but we don't know like zeus's role
in the film uh and he teased that crow
acts in a way that we've never seen
russell before just nice subtle yeah
he's a fabulous actor i just wonder
i am so excited and now growing slightly
concerned about thor 11 thunder because
there are so many amazing huge
personality actors that are in this
specific film and i'm like god i hope
it's i mean like kind of in the way that
like suicide squad was like a lot of
these people you love but they're only
going to be in for under two minutes
well that was also the tagline so you
saw that before right my problem with
russell crowe is like as long as he's
not singing it's going to be fine
because
he was horrible all
righty one
keep track of the cancer keep track of
the cancer
we're getting kids in here uh brandon
and maybe a couple other folks yesterday
as we were as we were casting our own
illuminati
namor's name got mentioned a couple
times yes
just because brandon's a more
responsible
reasonable person
i don't know just call out to me
in in an interview michael waldron again
confirmed that they had talked about
neymar being in the illuminati and
multiverse of madness but they couldn't
use him because the mcu had other plans
for him so he didn't make his way into
this particular movie with other plans
well i mean the this one rumor for quite
a while has been that he's going to
appear in black panther wakanda forever
i guess did they just not want that to
be his introduction with that well i
guess yeah because that would seem then
when you see him in black panther you're
like well i just saw this guy yeah or
even though i will say
yes and that would be cool we let's wait
and see him do we get neymar in the
first black panther wakanda forever
trailer well then they might as well
given him in uh maybe some madness right
uh okay
uh hey are you one of these weirdos that
thought there wasn't enough carnage and
death and multiverse of madness
um tommy bechdel t michael bech told i'm
looking right at you uh
well elizabeth olsen confirmed that
actually she was supposed to kill way
more people there are cut scenes of cool
like one-on-one fights particularly in
the camera taj battle scene there was i
mean it would be hard to kill any more
people in the uh 828 illuminati scene
because
literally everybody gets killed but
apparently there's gonna be a lot more
graphic violence she could have killed
like more of the uh what did he call
them lab coats could have killed more of
the scientists in the building was
always for lizzie to kill more
unfortunately they i like it they they
came and stopped me they said t michael
she can't kill everyone and i said can't
she she's the scarlet witch she's either
meant to rule the world
or destroy it look at that
smolder look at that
it's it's bordering on t michael it's
bordering on sideshow bob
um
okay
in another interview you know we're
getting tons of great interviews right
now with all the multiverse madness cast
we're getting lots of juicy quotes
benedict cumberbatch doctor strange
himself
mentioned that he passed on playing
malakith
uh in thor the dark world that was the
the villain played by christopher
eccleston right and and what is often
maligned as one of the worst mcu movies
though i know you particularly are a
low-key fan of that movie there's
there's a lot of good stuff in thor the
dark world that comes becomes very
important and they actually laid some
cool groundwork in that movie yeah it's
got its problems got its mess uh and
yeah malachith is kind of maligned for
being underutilized is a very powerful
force in the comics they kind of yeah
don't do them the justices in this and
like the makeup that
wears them so much you can't even tell
it's him yes i'm just happy that he
passed on it because he's such a good
doctor strange that i'm like if you
would have taken that role who would
have become doctor strange yeah maybe
tom cruise
and it is it is this fun thing of like
you know the mcu is probably only going
to give you one shot right so if you do
bite on a character that's like not
going to be a big deal or might get
killed off after one film like malekith
did maybe you miss out on i mean how
many experiences has benedict i don't
know i watched his interview with this
and it was really cute and fun because
he was talking about how he uh he like
read the spark notes to doctor strange
and was like this guy's kind of
misogynistic and kind of problematic i
don't think this is right for me and
they were like no no no we're playing
we're creating a doctor strange for
today it's going to be better it's for
the people of today it's not for the
people no no i didn't say i wanted to
change them
i just said talk me and talk about we
didn't have to base yeah your decision
on like the 1963 comic exactly
so once he was like as long as that is
played up that we are playing it for
today i'm down for it and also he was
like i really like playing arrogant he
was like it's very fun i was like there
you go he's got that
what happened
quiet please
just kidding
kidding
no laughter in this room i also want to
just really quick go to the questions
that people have been saying or what
people have been saying louis smith said
are the people who insisted that was tom
cruise was in the trailer doing okay
where was he yeah that i bet everything
on that it was mainly michael waldron
michael waldron's the number one tom
cruise stan also i'm excited for
maverick i'll say it
yeah our friends at imax who treated us
to a wonderful screening we we really we
we're hoping zach and i were laying it
on pretty thick yeah last night
how much we'd love let's just uh we're
about to move on to our break room
breakdown but we want to do a quick plug
so the the fine folks at imax had us to
their headquarters last night if you
follow new rockstars on social media you
might have seen a pic from this uh where
jessica tommy myself a bunch of other
staff and friends of new rockstars we
got to go re-watch because we'd already
seen it but we get to go see multi-verse
of madison oh there's that nice can you
find me
uh it's a little bit of a windmill
though there jessica's kind of hiding
but um we got to go see it at imax
headquarters here in los angeles on this
big beautiful screen uh it was just us
in alone in this this big cool theater
and and we actually later in this
episode we're going to talk about like
things we noticed upon second viewing
brandon wasn't there because he's
legally not allowed yeah in that
once the sun goes down i have to be home
let's just say he took the word max and
he took it a little too far
well that was almost r2d2 no my normal
screaming is my r2d2 voice and it's
can you do an impression of r2d2 chasing
brandon out of the parking lot
brandon yeah yeah
[Applause]
five days in a row that's when will it
stop zro cruel did ask jess to do the
art oh she's wrong i'm looking around
for their texts i'll do it again later
we'll be more prepared or i'll just make
a tick tock of it and send it to you
yeah yeah yeah
let's move on to the break room
breakdown camera number two
um
you guys vos mentions in the latest
episode of inside marvel that he uh did
today came out today right with whitney
my top i can't say the b word and mt a
small tidbit about quentin beck aka
mysterio wildly guessing like
fabricating a story that it's true about
the multiverse it's really weird let's
just take a look really quick
there have been various easter eggs that
we talked about hinting that the film
universe could have been connected to
616. so like in avengers in-game scott
lang storage locker hit 616 written on
the sign in spider-man far from home
mysterio quentin beck claimed to be from
earth dimension 833 whereas this
universe was earth dimension 616. and
we've talked about how weird that now is
considering quentin beck wasn't from an
alternate universe he was just
fabricating all of this so we just
happened to pull the right number out
which is hilarious at work well gutermin
was obviously a watcher or a tva agent
or something
only way it makes sense mr beck is from
earth
just not yours there are multiple
realities peter this is earth dimension
616. i'm from earth 833
i'm sorry you're saying there's a
multiverse so that
i'm obsessed with this i am obsessed
with this completely because it's just
like how was he able to just fabricate
these numbers that are absolutely
correct and i don't think he was
fabricating i think this has some i
think stark industries was testing and
working on finding the multiverse and
that's why everybody in that he did fire
that's later in no way home knows about
the multiverse exactly that would kind
of lean towards more like viz had his
theories that line yes you know
here's what i'll say here's what i'll
say i think there's a concrete answer
here and obviously i know it okay
there must be there's a reasoning
there's a reasoning why the multiverses
get numbered yeah and i don't think it's
like the first one we find gets number
one because cause christine palmer in
eight two eight three eight eight three
i keep saying two eight uh
how great would that movie have been if
we went to a28
christine 838 christine palmer with the
brighter red hair right she says that
she has been studying multiverses and
she numbered these right yeah so like
why wouldn't she number her own
multiverse number one or zero zero one
or something like that so i think the
the numbering system comes from
something about the multiverses like a
dewey decimal yes or when you look at
the multiverse under a microscope you
see a certain pattern or something what
do you think that christine and um quinn
beck's numbers wouldn't so their numbers
of each universe would align or you
think they have different numbers i
think i think they were both referring
to 616 as 616. okay because there's
something about the 6166 multiverse that
like whether it's biological whether
it's magnetic radiation something like
that right shows you oh this is 616. so
even if you've only ever seen one
multiverse you can look at your own
multiverse and know what number it is oh
i like that well and if if you know we
see the the the film strip from the tva
that loki saw that said 616 on it that
makes you think that like he who remains
numbered that 616. or that kang's have
set up the numbering system do you okay
so yeah okay keep going so maybe there's
a kang
already implanted in well
he remains keeping kang out of
616 until he's dead right but somehow
like tony
i i do like the idea that tony's looking
into multiverses because like he sees
the portal uh he's he's worried about
things coming in to uh come to earth
yeah he knows that they are aliens maybe
or maybe he has suspicions that they
could be aliens they could be coming
from another universe or something he's
looking into it and starts to see the
numbering system there's a kang in every
multiverse who's using the same
numbering system across first okay
so you think
okay
that's a great
oh that's a great
[ __ ]
game
if we say
thank you uh kenny c thank you uh hank
horse bradley and all the other folks
chrissy our friend chrissy with a fun
egypt fact we'll get to you later oh
you're perfect not ignoring you chris so
you're saying that the king the
conquerors
i say kangma conquers because of the
different variants came up with the
number system for the multiple that i
like that
yeah but then i guess how are they
disseminating that to gutermin who puts
it in mysterio's script
i'm pointed
okay so this is two theories that
probably are not correct with me but we
were talking about who now owns like
stark industries you know after he died
and also if they did dissolve the
company where the stuff go how would
they all know about it and what if
somehow stark or not start quentin beck
got a hold of information about the
multiverse through the stuff that was
dissolved and if that's true we also
talked about in a different universe
nathaniel richards did buy stark
industries oh so nathaniel richards aka
king the conqueror could have just had
that information so in 616 are we saying
that nathaniel richards is a grown man
buying no i'm i'm saying honestly yeah
so would that make like i'm just
thinking about like if they introduced
these characters into the 616 mcu
would we get john krasinski as like uh
like 60 year old reed
nathaniel richards can time travel oh
right now
that is yet another vector right we know
we can hop multiverses but also there is
time travel within each multiverse right
i think that like you know tony stark's
dead pepper
is ahead of stark industries but maybe
doesn't want to deal with it anymore
she's got a kid tony's gone her heart's
not into it you know we see happy is not
really working for stark industries
right and i don't think she would fire
the yeah has seized a bunch of the
technology 100 yeah and nathaniel
richards now that he who remains is dead
and a king from another universe could
come in as like nathaniel richards uh
who who pretended to be mr griffin who
bought uh stark industries in the comics
and turned out to be kang turning into
like industries with a queue uh
uh uh if if he's there now now that he
remains dead he can come in he can start
buying up uh stark tech to maybe prevent
prevent that multiversal knowledge from
getting out because he knows that it's
there right
the last warning from he who remains was
like if you kill me you have whatever's
coming next will be
way worse okay way worse a little side
note to that brandon brought up a great
idea which i'd
stop me if i'm saying it wrong i will
stop i already want to stop you because
you said you gave brandon credit for
coming in
what if our kang the conqueror won 616
is the air is just as arrogant and
refers to himself as like the number one
one when there's actually the other ones
are like no we're all each number one
it's just that we're all oregon i'm gang
working under tony might have been
working in a department that was looking
into multiple persons
tony i think maybe successfully made a
connection
and i was like naughty up in his phone
right
i'm wondering if he connected not with
a38 but another one and the reid
richards there was like stop
don't go any further and that's why also
in
when they come to him in endgame about
time travel he's like i don't want to
mess with this stuff because he knows if
they start poking around
other universes are gonna like that's it
that's a good theory and i know i
previously said i had the def definitive
answer but actually i just came up with
the even more okay
make it more definitive gutermin came up
with 616
in a dream
[Applause]
limousine riding jet setting kiss
stealing wheeling dealing son of a gun
zach huddleston
with a tear
in my eye
jack seems to think that tony knew they
ran a poll 72 percent of chad said that
tony knew about the multiverse i mean
he's a smart guy he's a very i just
don't i don't abide by the idea that
mysterio just got lucky i agree with
vaughn how are you going to randomly
pull those exact numbers out your butt
no yeah the odds of that are ridiculous
and in the the makers of these
properties would not have that beauty
exactly yeah there's also the small
possibility that he was from the
multiverse
came in
got this group of stark employees
together and
pretended he wasn't from the multiplayer
okay
as soon as x started running around with
his uh
is i'm the winner everyone said zaddy
someone put hashtag
ah
other things i'll take real clear this
awesome uh piece of merch right here
this is the latest obsession multiverse
amanda's shirt uh from
newrockstarsmerch.com this bad boy is
called
shattered madness
got a little dr strangey figure here
some shattered glass plays a prominent
role in the film you can get this and
that cool shirt that jessica's wearing
that cool villain shirt also available
uh from our merch partners uh
shirt oh and tommy's batman shirt
brandon and i are not currently wearing
new rock stars merch but you gotta say
tomorrow special as long as two of us do
philip won't fire us you say you gotta
be half merched up that's right i do
mine like every other day merch up from
the perch
from the rooter to the tutor we are
uh
we are merged big to butt okay
um
speaking of nose and tail dining uh our
good friends at hellofresh we would like
to thank them for sponsoring this
episode uh we truly are fans of
hellofresh here where you can get
yourself some farm fresh pre-portioned
ingredients and seasonal recipes
delivered right to your doorstep they
make home cooking easy fun and
affordable speaking of which brandon
cooked some hello friends oh yeah i got
myself a meal some delicious burgers all
right listen here it is
ingredients right look at that look at
that
[Applause]
and then there's the finished product
wow
delicious burger i really like amazing i
love these kind of like meal delivery
kits cause uh i i really like to cook
i'm no amateur i'm a pro dog i go harder
than they can
you saw the press i had for my cast iron
but i like these uh these kind of meal
things because i don't like planning all
the meals for the week get so much
pressure so much stress yeah give you
everything you need
it comes to your house boom easy and
like you can add stuff too i added a
little lettuce to the burger they didn't
give me the lettuce i popped it on there
why now you can really plus these things
up if you're if you're a real maestro in
the kitchen yeah you're a regular gordon
ramsay in there yelling at your wife to
get out of the way because she's ruining
you me me ruining me
only one in the kitchen there's too many
people in the kitchen it's a phrase and
a thing to live by the thing to live by
we have a tiny apartment kitchen yes oh
my god and you mentioned kind of adding
stuff uh they will also let you add
stuff right in the hellofresh interface
you could swap out protein side dishes
all those kinds of things you could pick
your favorites from 50 different weekly
options skip skip a week if you want to
maybe you're going to be traveling maybe
you're busy whatever skip a week change
your delivery date update your
preferences you can do it all in the
hellofresh app and we're going to be
eating hello fresh for at least the next
two days and i can't wait this week uh
including wait for there's some uh super
secret tommy bechdel hello fresh footage
oh yeah we're not sure if we're gonna
release that to the public i think i
think uh
michael baldwin confirmed that uh
actually there was originally going to
be a scene with uh with a storm in my
hello fresh footage tommy if i look at
this footage and there's one shot of a
butt
i'm going to be
if you want to join along with us or if
you just want to get yourself some
delicious food to cook at home go to
hellofresh.com
break room 16
and use the code break room 16. that 16
is important because you get up to 16
free meals
and three free gifts
head over there to that url it's in the
description of this video uh it helps us
out and you'll be helping yourself out
and anybody that you'll be feeding thank
you to hello fresh thank you to
hellofresh i want to point out there was
one comment in the chat that really
tickled my fancy
it said uh
zach would make my house a home
this is true
that's true and i think we all
feel that way feel that way uh you know
i just thought that that was very fun
mandatory fun whoa no
play my
[Music]
oh did i scare you away i'm so sorry
play it again
oh my gosh oh my god
the segment that has swept the nation
when we don't do it people are
devastated when we do do it people ask
me what is wrong
direct messages all the way from saudi
arabia i got one on twitter i'm saying
big fan of the show are you okay are you
drinking enough water the answer is
never to all ever
all right mandatory fun today is all
about getting canceled
we've all been canceled here before
last time we did this zach got canceled
for a really hot take that someone
requested he apologized for it
well guess what we don't apologize for
our cancelable takes yeah we dig deeper
is this america do we have free speech
yeah speaking of america america's about
to get burnt in this segment and i ain't
talking about this great nation i'm
talking about that character in this
movie because
i'm going to lay out a cancer we'll take
it right now oh no i'm going to go first
oh okay baton lead-off that's right
hit my camera
america's chavez you dumb dumb oh
dummy oh my god you are
one of the most powerful beings in the
multiverse there's only one of you you
are a unique all-spark
of a powered individual why
why after you humble the scarlet witch
do you go back to school
you go back to karma taj where you're
sparking out little sparks from your
sling ring you can move from universe to
universe what a waste of your talents
let me tell you a little anecdote guys
there was a time in my life where some
friends of ours that we all know chris
alvarado and dustin sterling and i went
bowling every single day for two months
okay the other two months i built a 209
no lessons respectable that's hard to do
209. that's a lot of strikes a lot of
balls
down the alley getting strikes
so we all said wow we're getting good we
pulled over 200. why don't we take a
lesson so we took a lesson from this old
guy and he taught us how to throw the
ball correctly it ruined bowling for me
forever america's chavez did not need
she doesn't need to learn how to ball
correctly she used to leap from
multiverse to multiverse to universe to
universe and do cool stuff maybe find
her mom's i don't know
her moms are still out there but guess
what she does she's got a little crush
on long and strange
so she's gonna go there and hang out
with the green
cow guy that we never learned anything
about
there's no explanation for it this is an
expanding cancer i'm sorry someone in
the chat said where is this goat
i don't know
i don't know where it's going but i'll
tell you where it's not going through
the multiverse because we're stuck in
coortage just doing circles with our
hands wasting our time and that's my
take tommy tommy officially against
charter schools that's right
public schools only school of hard
knocks is what he wants yeah uh i'll go
next i'll i i don't know if i can follow
that but i gotta pray cancel i think any
coherent taker follows that pretty
nicely this is a take for you hey guess
what chumps mordo is right boom all
right he's riding in the 838 he's right
in the 616. these sorcerers are a
problem there's too much dark magic
being used by people there's too much
rule breaking going on and it's getting
people killed my boy mordo was left in a
trench
at a bottom of a gutter with one cuff on
do you think christine's got to let him
out probably not the poor guy's just
trying to do his job okay he stepped in
when no one was willing to do it he's
right and he should kill dr strange we
just learned that all the doctor
strangers are bad they're all bad
someone's got to stop them that's my guy
mordo he's right nice word that's a
great take you know what if i had mordo
to stop that bullying instructor
i'd be i'd be at a local la bowling
establishment somewhere in the greater
l.a county area you can see mordo
leaning in and being like there's too
many bowling instructors
stan from shadow lanes must die the pin
comes due
okay i'll jump in because we're saving
jessica's for last because we think it's
going to be the best one
uh you know what loved this movie loved
it more on second viewing there was one
part that landed like a wet fart for
okay
that is
that i was jazzed coming out of the
trailers for it and i was unjazzed i was
easy listening
by the appearance
yes those
those beasts those monsters
in wonder gore
in the wonder gore temple okay those
things that should be the emissaries of
catholic right they have cthulhu-esque
uh you know uh type faces right these
should be like demons uh channelers of
pure evil and darkness
long uppercuts one
dead gone the others uh basically get
like a stiff breeze blow off the top of
the mountain gone forever
yes one gun these things are
unimpressive they do nothing is it i
mean someone said they said they don't
want the second
the second they the second uh wanda
shows up they take a knee they don't
even like swing and then see like oh oh
i didn't even realize we see zero
uh
evidence of any kind of power or
interesting capabilities from them
yeah i have a theory about this right uh
as wang and wanda enter that temple for
the first time we see that statue of
like uh an obsidian kind of scary
looking figure that has like kind of
like a big teeth kind of crazy looking
face that same image shows up in the end
credit kind of montage over the the
credits uh was that character supposed
to be maybe the model for the
uh the gamers i i like the idea that it
was for uh
maybe that was what cathode looks like
in our world anyways i wanted those
demons they're kind of like they're big
they're a part of that they're trying to
magic too yeah about to do some magic i
did nothing now not that wanda needed a
lot of help she's incredibly powerful in
that moment but i wanted them to do cool
stuff they did no cool stuff they should
have brought a few wizards for them to
chew on us great point great point
great point
great point jeff bring us home um mine
isn't my first one isn't cancelable you
guys we need to make sure that zaddy
don't lie becomes a saying on this show
because i want merch that's zach's face
and above it says zach
and on the back daddy just made this
house a home
oh and it's a picture just like a house
with a heart above it um you guys my
cancer will take which everyone thinks
is very hot i don't think it's hot i'll
say it right off the bat christine you
should have died
[Applause]
christine i want you murdered my girl so
the thing the reason why i want you
murdered is because
and this might be me talking out my
booty but in the uh on my butt butt but
then what if if it's an absolute point
that you die i want you to keep dying i
want you to die so many times i don't
want that metaphor crap that's like oh
our love is dead no i want her dad i
want her to be impaled on a steak i want
her to be the one that got hit by the
car i want her to be in the house their
apartment that caught fire like and what
if also i love me a story where the love
interest dies and i need this love
interest to die
heartbreak feels cool in a place like
that heartbreak if it does feel good in
a place like this kill christine um i
also
uh was about to use an analogy of
another movie but i realize a walk to
remember is probably not the best
analogy
but
i love that movie mandy moore shane west
you were like mandy more about ottoman
new york
charlize right yeah but christine rachel
mcadams if you're listening you should
have died and pray
to be only yours i pray
we'll walk to remember come on wow you
got the theme song yeah okay throw it in
the the chat i think we got a poll going
of who you think oh tommy leading with
the most cancellables i think that they
that polka first of all dodson fired
that pull off way too early jessica
hadn't even started her take yet
everybody's hating on the old team man
oh t baggy baggie
you know because then cause my cake was
a little too fiery some people worried
about me in the chat they know that i've
been cramping up lately and i was
yelling a lot but don't worry about it
have you been eating bananas
i've been eating nothing but them you
know one thing that can cause cramps
salt
dogs
as we wait for the chat we can do one of
the super chats uh yeah let's do the
super chat
man public man ass what do you guys
think the illuminati did with all the
infinity stones after they defeated
thanos oh they didn't have all of them
yet we know because thanos didn't have
all of them but in the original in the
comics the illuminati they do get the
infinity stones and they each take
to kind of keep it keep them like oh
yeah don't they uh they give them to the
different parts i imagine it's still in
the tva drawer or just
i mean
well probably in some kind of same vault
or something like that because yeah we
know like uh they weren't redistributed
to like who had them in the 616. like
the eye of akamoto is not on mordo's
chest with the time stone inside right
yeah really quick i want to acknowledge
my my girlfriend said why is jessica
obsessed with regina slash christine uh
you know damn well why i'm obsessed with
regina george oh my gosh it does look
like tommy was canceled at 40 percent of
the votes but that might be a timing
thing
i forgot about the grip
that hurt my feelings
john john getting revenge for having to
run mandatory fun graphics so many times
uh play that graphic again the cancelled
one no the kids will win we're out of
here
that was mandatory fun undecidedly not
cancelled part of this show it will
never die we will never take it away i
[ __ ] swear to you
it says tommy 40 just 27 zaddy 20. i
don't know if we had yeah we do we're at
20169.
updated fast enough he's too busy
launching the polls too early
and that's me being mandatorily cruel to
a person who works very hard on our show
and can't defend himself
hey you know somebody just threw in
tommy's take some of the best yeah
couldn't agree with him
i said that uh
now brandon uh
i'm just bringing your you guys went to
imax last night i was not allowed to
leave the house heard the court ruling
that's right what's that
don't ask about it but it starts beeping
let me know uh
i have seen multiverse amendments twice
we've all seen multiverse in manchester
it's really fun seeing it again for a
second time seeing what like the
audience is going to react to you kind
of get a chance to look around the
screen if you're at an imax you'll see
26 percent more on your screen
uh when you watch it but we all saw some
like different things watching it a
second time one thing i noticed i kind
of talked about this yesterday the
sequence of like portaling away at the
end of the movie right uh
uh
wanda has been defeated by being shown
what a terrible person she is to her
children uh and so america chavez makes
a star portal to take her and uh wong to
commentage
they go through the portal portal closes
uh uh
strange gets crushed with wanda
oh it's my baby there's a dog running
around on the floor if you're wondering
why the whole cast just looked down at
me it's my baby
and then when we see the portal open up
again it's to get christine and strange
out of the inky destroyed incursion
world yes and when that portal opens
that star portal they're at wonder gore
mountain again they're on uh america and
juan america and wong they're coming
from there so they went back to kamataj
and at some point go to wonder roar
mountain and then go back to game uh
stranger christine which would be weird
because they'll be bringing them to the
mountain it's like why are you bringing
them there i don't know i want you to
see it i want you to see what happens oh
my god maybe it's so strange to check
out the scene it's also not the mountain
it's the mountain next to the mountain
right because they can't get to this not
the greatest mountain in the world this
would also mean that like christine has
now gone to several multiverses herself
right i don't know if she ever did as a
scientist if she was just sending probes
i think i don't think she would i
thought that was a very interesting and
very purposeful for them to do that i
wonder if there's another scene they cut
oh yeah i don't know but that's
something i noticed on my second he did
show her his universe even briefly oh
maybe yeah yeah um and she's like why is
your pizza so flat yeah
this pizza's flat is it it's free for
some reason i think uh everyone's just
stealing pizza two things that i've
noticed um
which i was like ah was when their first
um when steven strange comes and sees
mordo and the candles go out i for i
when i was watching it i'm watching so
close for the dialogue i'm not really
paying so much attention to like what's
actually happening and when mordo starts
talking about the dream walking all the
candles go out in their sanctum and i
was like is she there i kept being like
is she there already or did he just do
this for dramatic effect and it made me
irritated um but then the second thing i
noticed was how sam raimi this movie is
yeah those ghosts being like come here
come here i was like this is evil dead
it is and danny elfman like that's like
like creepy chorus in his like kind of
score if there is like a good takeaway
from this i want people to really no
there's a lot of takeaways but mine is
like go watch evil deads and then go
watch this and you'll be like oh i
understand why they reached out to sam
raimi after scott derrickson to do this
yes yeah he definitely puts his his
stamp
and stamps and stamps and stamps and
stamps all over this movie including
like zooming in on the stamp as if it's
an eyeball or whatever right also the
like catchphrases of like uh christine
going see you yeah go back to hell i was
like yes yeah said they have to be
living yeah
i was like
you could see like 26 years ago if this
movie was made bruce campbell delivering
that line as doctors 100 i mean like
yeah elizabeth olsen giving the line of
like this is me being real yeah it's
like
[Music]
that was the thing that stood out to me
i thought she was great the first time i
watched this but man
every line delivery is
spot
on i literally was like they're doing
this in front of a blue screen and they
are doing so well what is the exchange
it's when america chavez finally like
gets up off the like the center
she's like uh-huh and she goes and then
she goes
i wanted her to do something a little
sassier like i loved it i thought it was
totally and in the end like she doesn't
really overpower wanda the only thing
she can do is like show her the literal
mirror
when zombie strange like throws like the
corpse demons at her she like looks
legit freaked out and scared like it was
good was great she's great yeah yeah
yeah i do i can go uh
one i didn't really
notice uh so much of the sound so much
of the music like in the regular theater
as much as i noticed in the imax one
thing i completely missed and i'm sure
everyone caught this
when charles xavier rolls in for the
first time they play the x-men the
animated series yeah like i miss it the
first time too
[Music]
like they just changed it a little bit
and it's but it's they credited at the
end in the end credits they credit the
songwriters and or song composers from
that tv show on the soundtrack which
kudos to them for getting more money
yeah and also kudos to like the
the kind of egolessness of raymie and
danny upman of being like this will be
fun and danny elfman are actually rather
this isn't the first time because in um
whichever one of the dc movies that
danielle took over for they merged like
several batman themes and john williams
superman theme into the movie
like they got permission obviously and
credited and they wove together these
like different iterations themes in i
just i don't know for me having not
noticed that the first time i thought it
was really cool and definitely worth a
second watch and i can't wait to like
you know buy this movie on digital and
watch it again when you said the dc
danny elfman for some reason the first
thing i was like nightmare before
christmas and then i was like that's
nice
did make the original batman yeah from
like the tim burton
on i think batman vs superman yes yes
him and junkie xl maybe like collaborate
on that we got a couple good uh super
chats that kind of are pertinent to this
conversation yeah uh and chuck vann uh
asks a great question
is 616 a universe or a multiverse does
zach have his plurality correct well if
if it's up to me i'm almost certainly
wrong yeah when he says like because
i've been saying like well you hop from
the 616 multiverse to the
828 multiverse but it's those are just
universes multiverse is the concept that
there are lots of universes yeah
the way we've talked about it before is
that like you have universes which are
separate within those universes you kind
of have like multiple timelines
kind of going together it's not like one
straight it's like a bundle of cables
right so you can kind of have variations
and branch timelines in one universe
but then there's like different
universes yes so the tva that we saw as
portrayed in loki right right they're
only operating in the 616 universe yes
wow that's why at the very in the very
last episode they do that thing where
they're you're hearing all the stuff
from marvel over the years and they zoom
out and you see two universes next to
each other and then they like zoom back
in to kind of establish like all this is
happening within one universe someone
said in the chat that it was justice
league when danny elfman had to take
over okay thank you sorry i didn't i
wasn't claiming to be an expert on that
one person also said batman too so i i i
might be both i just wanted to make sure
we either way it was cool i mean i i i i
if i acted as though i was the absolute
authority on that i apologize i just
meant that it happened before in reverse
almost maybe perhaps inspiring ej
menchaca brought up something that i
noticed also on a second viewing as we
talk about this mordo has like the
vaulting boots on him do that yeah in
the fight with trump yeah strange
parkours out of that little pit which i
thought it was going to be a bottomless
pit which would make more sense to like
separate them there's like an eight foot
it was like a little trench a little
trench uh uh so
he's asking like why didn't mordos
said
use
those
like i get what you're saying
yes that that limit inhibits your um
magic using ability also we only saw the
vaulting boots
used for lateral right thickness he did
not go
in the first like in the first strange
doctor strange movie he does it in
comments but we don't know we don't know
what this universe is he might just like
dude he's been relying on those boots
too much i know it's not going to be
he's not going
to say that that that that stunt is
pretty great because uh strange pushes
off of his chest
you need another party another guy down
there to get out he got folded like an
omelet um i like it i did that i like it
uh can he see i had a super chat said
imagine the dialogue between robert
giant junior stark and strange during
the illuminati sequence how would
strange have acted knowing he sacrificed
him in the 616 would scarlet witch
hesitated in killing like a robber to
donny jr she would have murdered robert
downey jr she was going to kill anyone
and everyone got it but it would be
interesting she didn't have to face
someone that she knew true you know what
i mean she didn't have to kill anyone
right face to face that someone like
like tony stark that she recognizes she
knew wong she knew strange she was
willing to kill that right right right
right
she never killed those yeah
intentionally several times i don't
think she did because i think she meant
to well the second time watching it i
was like she should have threw long like
three football fields into the abyss no
she got instead of just yeah she could
have gone yeah he turns into spaghetti
charles xavier today yeah yeah well also
interesting to note right like if
anybody's like oh uh
wanda got too savage she was too brutal
there right actually the character that
did the most damage in this was that
darker dimension strange yeah he said he
was traveling multiverses and killing
all the other strangers yeah yeah i mean
how nasty do you have to be to kill the
other versions of yours and what if he
was like absorbing their power but he
was dream walking into their bodies so
he said the feeling of getting pushed
but what he really was was making them
leap to their own deaths right like that
yeah you think they're capable of it
also i want i want to point out to that
last question i don't i mean he he
sacrificed tony with tony's knowledge
that he was gonna do it right like i
mean it wasn't like tony was like no no
no no no no no no no no i don't did i
think he never said to tony like hey
this isn't how the plan because they
never talked to remember they look at
each other and he goes
right but i think he it was implied that
like you know you have to die right well
there was still i still tony still had
to snap yeah i'll just say that yeah
let's hit some quick hit uh super chess
real quick uh d hunt says why has halo
not been covered yet well wait the game
the song about the other series there's
the series halo well have you been
watching the series i watched a couple
that my mom has and she updates me on it
because
one episode i did
just because i don't talk about it plus
you know what uh it's just not quite
popular enough yet
broadly for us to cover it but if it
becomes a big hit we'll cover it it's
just we kind of the audience dictates a
lot of our yeah if you guys want to play
the video game i'll play it with
emotional damage just sent us a how's it
going kind of cute little sticker and i
say it's going gucci to moochie baby
yeah i like
toku white says i'll take one for the
team and watch morbius tonight thank you
thank you so much
five dollars
anyone who goes to see more of this and
sees that that post credit has been
altered hit us up on twitter and yeah
also hashtag in our break if you want to
get real sly and do a little cell phone
oh no
don't do that oh you're absolutely right
we should do it we would never record we
were just putting in the the the mind
palace
which is my nickname uh what says what
other marvel property would you like to
see a horror adaptation of
quick
quick hits um like a [ __ ] i mean
age of ultron dude age of ultron make
those make ultron more scary make him
kill a child
well i would say it's a different kind
of horror but like
punisher
right that is like a
kind of graphic violent kind of horror
you could see like that you know tipping
into like hostile you know uh type
territory i think stanley's stripparella
for that okay
so he's a raw uh i mean bring back ghost
rider let's do ghosts let's go we're
ready do it the right way
nicholas cage back in the day take a
normal man and set his head on fire
chrissy we got to do chrissy's yeah
kevin christie thrown in an egypt fact
chrissy is our our friend who's an
egyptologist uh ancient egyptians loved
cats but they were never given names
they are always referred to as mew or
cat
because to name them was considered an
insult to the god bastet
i named my cat cat does that count oh i
guess i can't it is kind of amused that
counts thank you christie for that egypt
kevin said random but can the celestial
shape-shift seems like the celestials
and guardians of the galaxy one
was much smaller than what we saw yeah
because we saw one walking on a planet
and then like doing this and then
obviously the irishman was gigantic but
we also said yeah one with the head big
enough to like for that thousands of
people could live inside they can
shape-shift more than they can have
avatars kind of like what we saw every
the celestials exist outside of the
multiverse and then they project an
avatar of themselves into each universe
they're not like separate variants it
all leads back to like the one
so i think they can scale their size
however they want that's true because
it's kind they're messing with they're
there they're physical from what i
understand although i don't know how it
didn't cause the title
yeah i was like i don't think celestials
can come down i don't well you know in
the comics they've been on yeah i've
walked around on planets i don't feel
like i'm ever going to come down from
this amazing episode oh my god i do
unfortunately feel like it is almost
time to say goodbye is it time to say
goodbye well we've had a great time here
on the break room like we do every day
we hope you'll tune in tomorrow and
every day this week yes thank you for
all of your uh tips into the swear job
thank you thank you to everybody that
was doing super chats we tried to get to
a bunch of them apologies if we didn't
get to you um also we are two days out
from our very special very first yeah
that's right friday the 13th and this is
this is crazy don't talk about it i was
here late again last night
and i felt just like a
breeze brush against the back of my neck
and i was like is there a window open
turns out there are no windows in this
window completely windowless prison
so i don't know it's weird there's been
flickering lights i've noticed like a
pair of work boots that don't seem to
belong to anybody every once in a while
on my workplace well i don't know that
we'll get to explore that on friday but
maybe okay um also the next two days
we're gonna have special guest uh
co-hosts so tune in to see who that
might be i bet they're familiar faces to
you if you watch the new rockstars
channel um but all of that said
thank you so much for joining us yes
have a great rest of your wednesday
we'll see you soon bye everybody
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
true
[Music]
you